welcome to this video playing no I
promise to play the Dutch sometime so
here we go again semi Noah from from
Russia let's see yeah the staunton
gambit community to probably is its c6
on light f7 first I I do forget this
quite quite often I've played this
sometimes from the white side and they
also have problems too to remember c6
yeah I think so and Queen a five I guess
want to put some pressure on d5 yeah
they can take with the night or the
Queen let's see how to continue it's a
typically weird position like it
sometimes happens in the end the Dutch
defense Bishop
hard to tell how to how to develop here
however maybe I can hmm it's really a
strange position thinking about how to
how to play here I mean maybe as weird
as it sounds maybe I can just after
Queen I try to put the King on the aid
and and did you know all that here can
also give the check here I want but not
clear that this helps me in any way I
fear that you might take here until 1 d6
ok let's let's let's just keep it closed
you can give this check but I'm not sure
that this is leading to so much hang on
da tis it's obviously a obviously weird
but how bad is a Trillium ok maybe maybe
I should should prevent 94 what a weird
position Jane's he should give the check
so much is clear my idea now was to play
the Queen here and then Queen h6
possibly or queen f5 maybe look be eight
and b5 is also also possible
units not playing with memberships at
the moment which is a somewhat weird I
Scott 94 now
maybe maybe I'm thankful he really takes
it greedy that is greedy very very
greedy let's not mind the self Pena hmm
but I don't don't really see how to use
it maybe maybe f5 and 3g for something
like that wow this this this happens if
you play an opening it's super super
complicated opening like the Dutch and
don't know really what's going on down
on time and no idea about the position
yeah i thought this should actually be
be still quite okay for me but maybe I'm
wrong and I teff son I completely forgot
about night to f7 but he also is not not
playing it okay so what is this porn
donia what a horrible game turn to
absolutely correctly position even 96's
move him probably
not the only one of course it can play
all kinds of things i still haven't
moved my c8 bishop of course not yeah
man what a game really lucky to I mean
the position is this lost but really
lucky that then I'm not let say a bunch
of pieces down after how the game I mean
how weird my position was and then still
is maybe I get in rookie too but he can
play route g5 him with her with the
counter play time money gypsy too but it
is itself and have not a really really
great great idea
oh man this is this is what you get for
playing playing this openings some some
activity hook f a Droog f21 it some sort
of activity we can make an very easily
stop stop things probably Bishop f5 for
example was a good way to do it I mean
when you waste many ways to win but this
is a bit more than I actually expected
to get check
check okay rookies always good but check
the apron maybe the apron you can just
play basically anything Jeff
unfortunately there is this pawn as well
okay yeah this was resigned opening
disaster from the first grade opening
disaster yeah I don't really know this
opening I have played it once or twice
with white and I know that something
like that with Queen 85 is how it is
play but I probably have to take here on
d5 I don't know after this Flula it
already feels a field strange for black
at this point I was acting so
pessimistic I mean long-term I have to
have two bishops very long term and the
position is held it closed I know it
looks like rubbish but maybe I'm maybe
there are some some way Mary some way to
play it compounds to go be fine if yeah
maybe I should have done that and here
maybe queen age 67 Queen age six Queen
g7 Toronto to get to get the Queen back
him I mean I found it very cheeky that
he took on on age 70 but he can probably
do it there is nowhere no way to exploit
this and Jim it's just it's just a
terrible position what can you do he
probably could have won even quicker but
this is just a total of total mess you
know yeah the opening is just just too
bad the opening results to add
maybe I maybe I need to take poor it's
very difficult to play this without any
knowledge funny the comp ones to go be
five year quim one point and queen takes
a six and Bishop d7 so basically a
gambit to get some stuff developed yeah
I don't know this is a certainly a
dangerous line for black it's a little
bit unlucky that I got such a such a
brutal line against my opening here I
mean and no one bit of the Dutch but
those sight lines not so much okay
thanks for watching